PROFESSOR: In this
video lecture,
we're going to introduce
the idea of directed graphs,
or digraphs for short.
So normally and
before this class,
you might have thought of graphs
as being something like this.
Y is a function of x and
graphed on the xy plane.
But that's not what we
want to be thinking about.
Instead, we want to think
about something like this.
This is a graph to a
computer scientist.
Show a bunch of vertices, which
are those point that you see,
and edges, which
connect vertices.
Being more specific
and direct about this,
it's composed of a
set V of vertices
and a set E of edges, which
are composed of 2V each.
The way you write that
out, an edge is v comma w,
and that specifies an
edge going from v to w.
And in the graph, it would
look something like this.
Note that they are directed.
That an edge from v to
w is not the same thing
as an edge from w to
v in a directed graph.
For example, here we
have one directed graph,
and you write out vertices as
the set of all the vertices
you see there.
And edges are pairs of vertices.
You can also
realize that digraph
is the same thing as a binary
relation on the vertices,
because each edge just
defines the relationship
from one vertice to another.
So, every binary relation
can be drawn out as a graph.
You just put each of the things
in each of the sets as vertices
and edges being the
things that relate
from one set to the other.
So, now we're going to
define walks and paths.
Now, a walk follows
successive edges
but it can repeat
vertices or edges.
For example, I can start
at the black vertice there,
and we can go to red,
blue, yellow, red.
And w can go back to blue again.
There's nothing stopping us.
And the length of
these paths is not
how many vertices
we've gone through,
but the number of edges
that we've gone through.
So here, the length
would be five
because we went from white
to black, black to blue,
blue to yellow,
yellow red, red blue.
It's not the six vertices
that we went through.
And you have to be
careful about that,
because that difference
of one kind of gets you.
A path, on the other hand,
walk through vertices with that
repeating a single vertex.
So, for example, start at
blue, you can go to yellow,
you can go red, you can
go pink, you can go green,
but then we're stuck.
We can't go back to red.
We've already been there.
So, that's it.
That would be the
end of our path.
If we went to red again, then
it wouldn't be a path anymore.
Not be a valid path.
And here, the [INAUDIBLE]
length is four edges, not
five vertices.
And every graph
can be represented
as a matrix representation.
You draw it out like this.
And what we're going
to do is if there's
a edge that goes from one of the
things on the right over to one
of things on the top, we'll
put a one at that position.
For example, there's an edge
that goes from the black
to the red.
So, on the black row
in the red column,
we're going to put in a one.
Same thing, there's one that
goes from black to green.
We'll put black row, green
column, put in another one.
And so on for all the edges
that we have in our graph.
And the rest we just
filled with zeroes.
And this is called
an adjacency matrix.
And as you can see, it
uniquely defines a graph.
Every edge is represented here,
and every one of the vertices
is represented here.
So, any graph can be
drawn up this way.